so staying healthy
staying healthy comes in two parts your
physical health and your mental health
and intermountain healthcare the
sponsors of our next segment are teaming
up with the raider rats to do just that
and here to tell us more is physical
therapist allison carr and raider its
director tiffany mcniff welcome you too
hi thank you so much for having us thank
you for being here and thank you guys
for what you're doing now intermittent
health care is providing football's
fabulous females with just a number of
services so what exactly are you guys
doing allison so i'm the physical
therapist for the radarettes um i'm also
working with an athletic trainer as well
from intermountain and the two of us are
on site every day for rehearsals to be
there for the dancers and whatever they
need for their orthopedic needs the rest
of the team that we have is a dietitian
for nutrition services and then also a
sports psychologist for all of the
mental health and then we also have a
sports
medical doctor and he's there for any
second opinions that we might need it
really is not just about
looking pretty and and rooting on the
team these are athletes and they need
the training not just physically and
mentally tiffany can you tell me a
little bit about what's involved with
with being a raider edge absolutely we
perform at 10 games a year in addition
to so many different community events
and appearances
and we practice anywhere from 9 to 12
hours a week
so being a professional athlete
comes with injuries and now having the
resources with intermountain health
to get these ladies back on track and
give them a clear path forward has been
absolutely fantastic what a great
partnership it really is i mean these
women have so much going on not just
physically but also the mental demands
tell us a little bit about that well
being a professional cheerleader is a
part-time job so outside of this we have
you know teachers on the team we have
lawyers we have students
we have recent grads so
their schedules are extremely demanding
and you know coming off of a pandemic
just having the support that they need
to talk to someone to help them on their
day-to-day life has been incredible
let's talk a little bit about behavioral
health ellis and maybe you know a little
bit more of what how intermountain
health care offers in that department
sure so our sports psychologist is very
knowledgeable in sports
specifically sorry um she really kind of
understands what the dancers need she
was also an athlete as well so she
understands kind of how your mindset
really needs to be fine-tuned to exactly
what you're doing in the moment they
have to learn all of these complex
routines to different you know sets of
music it's very impressive
so they really have to be laser focused
so it's important that they have that
kind of mental awareness and yeah
intermountain healthcare has so many
services to help everyone become better
and you're doing that for one of the
most famous groups of women out there
and and i hope you are also to partaking
in these services because i got to
imagine running the show it gets pretty
taxing on you too right absolutely and
they have been extremely helpful to both
myself my staff and all of my team we
love it and we love intermountain
healthcare thank you again to intermouth
and healthcare for sponsoring this
segment for more information visit
raiders.com
forward slash champ